aussi sur le 6 6 2 6 1 et très vite
aller le 6 le 6 8 2 6 qu'est ce qui se
passe avec le 6
c'est parti vite ah ouais vous et vos
travers des exemples si j allais vite on
est on est pressé allez tous les matchs
au lambeau crocodiles tuent tout arrive
allez on y va alléger les soirs ce que
j'ai reçu je dis stop à balan si je suis
bel et bien vous inquiétez pas nous à
web tv ne lis pas je suis désolé c'est
obligé de le dire ou pas quoi bon je
suis derrière un boulot ce mode c'est
pas sûrement opus ne perçoit pas sur
elle non mais il est maqué lui non les
maths ni makelele mais ça vous a quitté
la route
on est mal non ces petits pas dans cette
mauvaise idée non mais n'allez retrouve
avec moins bien c'est le sait le cabba
scélérat non vous n'allez pas plus loin
c'est pas parce que sinon vous avez dans
le bas du tout le temps mais ça y est
parce que je crois c'est cela
[Applaudissements]
alors oui kkg c'est la mêlée que je gère
ça vous il ya un instant à jouer au baby
phone et vous devez lire vos trois
derniers c'est m alors vous faites ce
que vous voulez mais je sais qu'il ya un
mois je vous le dis on peut pas le dire
on peut pas dire le nom il ya juste une
personne qui a dit quoi
voilà c'est qu'ils abondent qui remplace
kelly voilà c'est quelqu'un qu'on
connaît que vous connaissez on peut pas
dire de qui il s'agit mais quelques
erreurs
écoutez moi bien je sais prendre jusqu'à
qui décident 30 chez ce cas à sadi et
francesca apparemment ne peux pas
dévoiler non c'est vrai pas me francesca
ben non ça en fait elle a très envie de
dévoiler non mais bon c'est quelqu'un
qu'on connaît c'est quelqu'un de licques
bas c'est bête qu'elle revienne plus
dans l'émission quoi c'est quelqu'un de
l'équipe mais qui n'est pas là ce qui
n'est pas là ce soir
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à vous dire
dites à quelqu'un un homme qu'elle dit
là exactement il est très sympathique et
il travaillait au ministère au ministère
de quoi la commission européenne rohs
[ __ ] j'ai poussé mon jeu